the key to the volkswagen's tour egg
success is its flexibility says our car
expert klaus neetzitz
it's been a best seller in north america
russia and china and sold over 300 000
units
vw has given the latest model an updated
design
and packs some brand new features under
the hood klaus is going to give us a
look at what the new touareg is packing
the new toureg features the latest
innovations from vw's trustee engineers
visually the look is much the same as
older models
but vw has reworked the bumper and added
a pair of their
new by xenon headlights to the package
the biggest changes are under the
bodywork
vw redesigned the suspension the driver
assist system and drivetrain
klaus has brought the touring to an
off-road course to see if the suv
lives up to the name he's excited to try
out the powerful engine
and specialized eight-speed transmission
including
mid and rear differentials in other
words everything you need to get out of
a jam
let's take a look at what it can do
the tour egg really is designed for
off-road conditions
if you want to tackle tricky terrain
with steep slopes
streams and bumps then the two thousand
euro terrain tech package
is the right choice for you
this knob is used to lift the suv using
the turreg's air suspension it can raise
the suv's chassis
by 30 millimeters that gives the wheels
more room to maneuver
and can help prevent collisions
close says small hills like these aren't
a problem thanks to the air suspension
system
the new touareg also sports an
overhauled v6 engine
which vw says is more fuel efficient
than previous models
the touareg is claimed to need 6.9
liters of diesel
for 100 kilometers the engine produces
193 kilowatts of power
and 580 newton meters of torque stats
that impress
our reviewer clouds and the v6 tdi
engine
also fulfills the eu's emission
standards the 3-liter engine features a
urea injection exhaust system and an
addition scr catalytic converter
it's amazing what suvs can do says klaus
it's just a shame that most people who
drive them never get to really
experience them off road
the steep slopes you might get stuck but
the tourx electronics
automatically prevent the suv from
rolling backwards
but if the green terrain light is
flashing that means the suv
has detected a downward slope and will
engage the brakes
you might need a little bit of courage
to take your foot off the brake
but the system works
and now on to the next stage
the touareg is also at home on the
street the eight-speed automatic shifts
smoothly in all driving conditions and
the new transmission is also more fuel
efficient
when the driver takes their foot off the
gas the engine is decoupled from the
drivetrain
and starts idling that helps save fuel
the turret gets on just fine on regular
roads it's a sporty comfortable suv that
boasts really good handling at high
speeds
outside of the city it's a safe and good
all-around
suv thanks to its all-wheel drive
the tour egg drives like a big station
wagon that's built for long distance
trips
but the tour egg isn't cheap our test
model sticker price is just under 58 000
euros
the new tourig is really an improvement
says klaus it offers sound handling on
the street and great performance
off-road
that's why it's one of the best in its
class
you